also breaking tonight tensions extremely
high in and around minneapolis again
after three nights
of violent protests following the
killing of dante
wright by a police officer over the
weekend prosecutors say they will charge
that officer who killed dante wright
with second degree manslaughter
she has been arrested all of this comes
against the backdrop of the trial just
down the road
for the former minneapolis police
officer accused in the death of george
floyd
senior correspondent mike tobin is again
in brooklyn center minnesota tonight
a mug shot for a veteran police officer
kim potter is charged with second degree
manslaughter and facing the possibility
of up to 10 years in prison
a statement from the washington county
attorney's office says she will be
prosecuted vigorously
officer potter abrogated her
responsibility to protect the public
when she used her firearm rather than
her taser
the body camera shows what the former
chief described as a fatal mistake
a traffic stop that turned to a struggle
potter pulled her sidearm instead of her
taser
and killed 20-year-old dante wright
police say the stop was for an expired
tag officers discovered wright had an
outstanding warrant for possessing a
pistol without a permit
the struggle ensued when wright resisted
arrest activists and family
don't accept that narrative it boggles
the mind
why she would pull him over in the first
place
or is it the rules of set aside when you
really being targeted for driving while
black
with demonstrators gathering nightly
left-wing lawmakers like alexandria
ocasio-cortez
indicted all policing with a tweet dante
wright's killing was not a random
disconnected
accident it was the repeated outcome of
an indefensible system
that grants impunity for state violence
rewards it with endlessly growing
budgets at the cost of community
investment
and targets those who question that
order you are hereby
ordered to immediately disperse a
protest at the police station
again turned to rioting techniques now
standard at anti-cop demonstrations
included fireworks umbrellas
shields and random fires bricks and
bottles hurled at police
police responded with gas and flashbangs
upwards of 60 arrested we are not going
to tolerate the activities that we've
seen
the past couple of nights
the mayor of brooklyn center mike
elliott says city council banned the use
of tear gas however he also said the
hennepin county sheriff
is commanding the law enforcement
response to rioting and curfew
enforcement
as you can see another crowd is
gathering another curfew is in place
for 10 o'clock local time brett
mike tobin live in brooklyn center mike
thank you